[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie welcome back to
my Game of Thrones Season 4 countdown
and if you hadn't noticed I just changed
my channel avatar it's just meant to
look a little bit more like my face so
for this video I wanted to talk about my
top 10 characters on the show especially
given where things are headed in season
4 the thing is you know from season to
season my favorites tend to change so my
favorites from season 1 aren't
necessarily my favorites right now all
that being said as I you know work my
way down to my own number one favorite
character the big question we need to
ask and try to answer is who is the most
important character in A Song of Ice and
Fire
not necessarily the coolest or the most
powerful character the most important
character like if you had to say Song of
Ice and Fire is about one person that
would be the character we're talking
about no the most important so real
quick before we get started though I'm
gonna do one more countdown video
tomorrow morning and then Sunday night
I'll be posting my review video and
we'll just get into it so also if you're
finding me for the first time I'm doing
a weekly giveaway for each of the review
videos all you have to do to participate
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on each of those review videos so I'll
provide more details about that tomorrow
though so let's get started dragons are
coming so here's my top 10 characters on
the show careful for potential spoilers
if you're not caught up on season 3 or
the books up to where we're at in season
3 right now but here we go number 10
Daario or I guess you could say the new
Daario since we're also kind of talking
about actors he mostly makes the list
because the character is such a big part
of Daenerys story and she's also on this
list I feel like the people who are most
important to the most important people
are sometimes also the most interesting
characters Daario as we've seen him so
far as essentially you know the special
forces leader of Daenerys army you know
yes grey worm is technically the leader
of the army but Daario is the person she
calls on for the most important
political missions and doing the covert
dirty work the swagger the character has
is also just so much fun given how
proper the rest of Danny's inner circle
is you have two knights who are almost
yes-men and a few influential women but
Daario is one of the few people that
just kind of does whatever Daario wants
to do adding sex into the equation you
know with him and Danny makes it so much
more fun and actually funny when you
talk about his relationship with the
other male advisors in her inner circle
I'm hope
since they recast the role that they do
give him a lot more scenes from the
books and based on the clips we've seen
so far of him he looks really promising
so the new actor looks like it's gonna
be really awesome
number 9 Sansa Stark you may have
written her off earlier just because of
all the she's taken from the
Lannisters so far but I think that she's
gonna surprise you in season 4 we also
have to acknowledge how much sophie
Turner is matured as an actress since
the show started I feel like they keep
giving Sansa more to do each season just
because sophie Turner has become so much
more compelling you know as things get
progressively worse for her character I
also want to say that because of sophie
Turner I love TV show Sansa so much more
than book Sansa right now one of the
really interesting unintentional side
effects of her character's demeanor is
is that she's kind of viewed as a flower
you know other characters tend to
overlook her with the exception of
Joffrey should she gets to be front and
center for some of the biggest and best
scenes just because you know no one is
really looking at her I'm really looking
forward to seeing how sophie Turner
interpreted Sansa is all these new you
know season four mega events start to
unfold number eight Melisandre the lady
in red
even though Daenerys brought Dragons
back into the world Melisandre is the
most visible symbol of magic on the show
she has this whole sex dynamic to it
that really makes you afraid and turned
on at the same time like imagine how
Kendra felt with the sex leeches you're
disgusting terrifying and awesome at the
same time she's also one of the wisest
characters in the show next to Tyrion
and Varys
from an educational standpoint she kind
of feels like a maester who just isn't a
maester they really did tease the wall
on that last Dragonstone scene from
season 3 so what I'm most looking
forward to from Melisandre in season 4
is how she interacts with Jon Snow and
the other characters of the wall and
watching Jon Snow interact with her he
has a really spotty track record with
sexy gingers so it's gonna be a lot of
fun number 7
Oberyn Martell the red Viper of Dorne
for a lot of people who haven't read the
books he's a totally new character which
is one of the reasons why I like him so
much
you know he's fresh meat for the King's
Landing grinder he also brings Dorne
into the story in a much bigger way it's
like a whole region of Westeros we just
haven't seen yet one of the coolest
things about you know big epic stories
like Ice and Fire is that they're
literally big places so you don't just
get stuck
with the same group of characters for
seven or eight seasons of all the new
characters coming in the near future I
think he's one of the best I really hope
we actually get to see more of Doran in
season five but this year I'm most
looking forward to watching him fight
that's essentially what his reputation
is being one of the best fighters in
Westeros and because of the different
culture of Dorne he has this really
unique fighting style that's different
from all the Knights of King's Landing
we've actually seen some clips of that
so it's really looking awesome
number six Brienne of Tarth probably the
only true knight in Westeros Brienne was
so awesome in season three in watching
Wendell and Christy with Nikolaj
coster-waldau was one of my favorite
things I could watch a whole season of
just the two of them together world's
best Odd Couple Brienne is probably the
most noble person in Westeros right now
even as early as that first episode you
get the sense that just because people
are Knights didn't mean they're
honorable you know playing the game of
Thrones and all Brienne is one of the
only characters that does not give a
about any of that she just has this
beautiful dream of knighthood and it
works so well when you juxtapose it with
someone like Jaime Lannister who
essentially you know up to a certain
point doesn't care about anything you
know I think he thinks he cares about
Cersei but he has doubts about you know
even that so it's like pure belief and
nihilism just walking around next to
each other
the thing that I'm looking forward to
most from her character is watching her
adapt to things in King's Landing
because it's just a cesspool but
remember she also kind of gets credit
for bringing Jaime back so I'm really
looking forward to seeing him try to
repay her in a really earnest way number
5 Arya Stark stabby death machine in
training all the clips of Arya that
we've seen from the trailers have been
action scenes and heard in the middle of
a warrior training montage with needle I
just love how dark she is it's this
whole level of complexity that Sansa
hasn't quite got to and something that
goes way beyond where Jon Snow or bran
are despite all those characters have
been through she's one of the few
characters in the show that actually
embraces the direction she's headed
you know revenge machine how appropriate
that we saw the Titan of Braavos in one
of those trailers you know kind of
heralding the return of the faceless
ones or heading in that direction on top
of all that you also can't talk about
her without talking about the Hound
you know of all the twosomes on the show
she in the Hound are my second favorite
you know behind only Jaime and Brienne
it says a lot about who the strongest
characters are when you see who rubs off
on who for instance bran is a much
stronger character than Jamie right now
so she rubs off on him and Arya is a
much stronger character than the Hound
in a really intense dark way
so she rubs off on him and it's just
hilarious it really is funny when you
think about how a small character has
such a big influence over such a vicious
character like the Hound number four Jon
Snow
he's such an easy fan favourite because
you feel like the character has so much
potential and Kit Harington is just so
awesome at it
they're actually a lot of things in the
story that make you feel like he's
destined for greatness so you know he's
in my top 5 mostly because I feel like
he's gonna be one of the focal points of
the story as things move into winds of
winter I think one of the biggest
problems of season 3 was that he had to
go off on his own with the wildlings you
know yes it was a ton of fun watching
him react to Ygritte
you know guess which one of them had the
stronger personality but he didn't
really get to interact with any of the
other characters I loved ciarán hinds
'as mance rayder but he was barely in
the story and a lot of the wildlings
with the exception of Ygritte and Lord
of bones were very forgettable Giants
notwithstanding the thing that I'm most
looking forward to from him in season 4
is him taking more of a leadership role
you know it's time to grow up boy we've
actually seen some scenes of him and Sam
in the library so I'm really looking
forward to them dealing with you know
one the wildling army - angry
ex-girlfriend gingers and three
hopefully some new White Walkers number
three Tyrion Lannister so despite being
stuck in what looks like the black cells
for most of this season I feel like
going forward he's gonna be one of the
most if not the most important character
Tyrion is one of the most interesting
characters in this show just in general
for two really big reasons one george RR
martin has said that he identifies with
him the most so I feel like he expresses
that character in a much deeper way and
to Peter Dinklage is one of the best
actors on the show there was actually
this really cool thing Dinklage said
about acting in a sword and sandal show
like Game of Thrones he said that
because it's just a grand setting actors
tend to overdo their performances a lot
like cranking the acting nob 211 but he
has this really subtle way of delivering
lines or saying things and using
gestures that just comes across so much
more effectively than yelling your lines
ever could
that's why I feel like HBO kind of makes
him one of the centerpieces of the show
you know from a marketing standpoint
next to Emilia Clarke the thing that I'm
most looking forward to from cheering in
season four is watching him repay all
his debts because a Lannister pays all
his debts
sometimes with revenge number two Jaime
Lannister so there's been so much Jaime
and all the trailers and clips that I
feel like next to Tyrion he's gonna be
one of the most important characters and
Kings Landing this season
yes purple wedding and all there's lots
of stuff going on but think about the
entire season as of the end of season
three he's undergone one of the biggest
character transformations next to Theon
there's so much of Brienne stability in
him now I just can't wait to see how he
deals with all this going down at
King's Landing the golden hand is just
the icing on the cake it's just a visual
sign of that transformation you know on
top of both keeper and being part of the
white cloaks mark my words by the end of
season four Jaime will be one of your
favorite characters if he is not already
I would say the thing I'm looking
forward to most from Jaime in season
four is seeing him deal with all the
biggest changes in King's Landing like
Cersei for instance who is changing a
lot herself he's gonna be leading the
white cloaks and I don't think he's
gonna become another Barristan Selmy but
I do think he's gonna try and become the
kind of person bran would respect and
admire plus there's him learning to
fight with his left hand with bran they
actually changed that from the books for
all you readers out there and my number
one favorite character Daenerys
Targaryen you know just thinking about
season four I feel like she's gonna be
one of the most important characters
this year Joffrey is king of Westeros
but he's really just a figurehead
Daenerys is earning her kingdom one
freed slave at a time you know then
there's the Dragons on top of all that
of all the things HBO pumped up in the
trailers it was definitely the size of
the Dragons now you know even on the
Black Friday South Park episode it was
all about dragons are coming they're
collectively always going to be at least
the second most important characters in
the Song of Ice and Fire no matter what
happens and they're there because of
Danny the thing that I'm most looking
forward to from Daenerys in season 4 is
her trying to be a real Queen you know
not just a general like she was in
season 3 that story arc was all about
conquering now she has to learn how to
rule but think of it as like a practice
run for the Iron Throne and just
acknowledge
Emilia Clarke's contributions you know
she's doing such an amazing job of
portraying someone who is essentially
just a little girl learning to be a
general and then the mother of dragons
and now Queen on top of all that
remember Daenerys isn't a whole lot
older than Arya so we should think of
her is like a child leader prodigy but
now it's your turn let me know who is
your favorite character on the show and
who is your favorite actor on the show
too they don't necessarily have to be
the same so like I said tomorrow I'll be
posting my next countdown video that'll
be my top 10 moments from season 3 and
then that night I'll be doing my episode
run review be sure to subscribe to get
everything and participate in the
giveaway it's gonna be a ton of fun
right now click here to watch all my
other countdown videos and finish
getting ready and click here to watch
all my trailer breakdowns thank you so
much for watching
dragons are coming tomorrow the wait is
over high-fives everyone
[Music]